this idea that conventionalism is
restricted to people of the right
the conventionalism is just about booze
wah middle-class values is just not true
conventionalism is about adhering to the
moral standard that is promulgated at
the time so on campus conventionalism is
not of the right right I'm at the center
here now normally across America if I'm
in Alabama that I'm conventionalist
right if I'm in Texas I'm a
conventionalist although in fire in
Alabama I wouldn't vote for I more but
if I but if I were but conventionalism
depends on where you are at the time so
if you're inside the institution like
UCLA or the conventional view is a very
left-leaning one then your orthodoxy of
obedience to Authority is conventional
so if you believe that the campus has to
be ruled from above by the
administrators who are going to tell you
what's right and wrong you are
conventionalist right so the inherited
values are not conventional middle-class
ones here on college campuses they are
inherited values of the left and as you
see here on campus obedience and respect
for authority to the left is required if
you dissent then it is very likely three
and four times they attempt to impose a
policy where you have to pay a specific
security fee if less than seventy
percent of the people who show up in a
crowd are from the University campus
three out of three of the four times
that policies have been used it'll be
used against the dissenters because
obedience to the left obedience to
Authority is key
so obviously this elements of
authoritarianism exists on the level